le soleil attendaient les habitants de
kiev ce matin il n'avait pas mis le nez
dehors depuis 48 heures mais ce n'est
pas ce qu'ils ont d'abord remarqué à
l'horizon missiles russes délibérément
lancé sur des appartements comme disent
les ukrainiens erreur de cible du
système de défense anti-aérien comme ont
riposté les russes
du rizal cas colonel à la retraite a été
réveillé en stupeur par l'explosion dans
l'édifice qui fait face aux siens mais
il vient le voir pour la première fois
ils préfèrent croire à une erreur
je pense que c'est une tragédie pendant
la deuxième guerre mondiale on pouvait
comprendre qu'ils étaient nos ennemis
mais là ce sont nos frères les frères
avec qui nous avons combattu contre le
fascisme je ne peux toujours pas croire
que c'est la réalité je préfère le voir
comme une erreur et bien sûr je souhaite
la paix
pour avoir la paix il faut mieux faire
la guerre prend le leader du parlement
lui aussi sorti de son bunker pour
constater les dégâts stop pour cuba où
il a troqué le costume cravate pour le
kaki militaire
watch dont on n'a plus beaucoup de temps
le temps ce sont des enfants morts n'ont
pas mort ce qu vise-t-il mais des
enfants tués et femmes tuer des civils
c'est des infrastructures qui sont
détruites je veux demander à tout le
monde de cesser les procédures
bureaucratiques et d'agir d'où
tout juste après notre rencontre ousmane
stéphane shoot retrouver le président
volodymyr zielinski pour signer une
demande officielle d'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'union européenne
48' redécouvre fait ça veut aussi dire
que les provisions à la maison sont à
sec depuis ce matin les enfants la queue
pendant des heures pour pouvoir se
procurer quelques biens essentiels dans
le peu de supermarchés qui ont ouvert
leurs portes aujourd'hui
ils ont patienté sans broncher pendant
plus de trois heures ici il n'en
ressorte qu'avec l'essentiel parce qu'il
faut bien tous tenir
à kharkhiv les combats ont été brutaux
aujourd'hui la deuxième ville d'ukraine
près de la frontière russe a été prise
pour cible par les bombardements russes
au moins 11 personnes y ont été tuées
selon le gouverneur régional
impossible de se courir la population
sous les bombes
aujourd'hui nous a démontré que ce n'est
pas seulement une guerre mais le meurtre
de notre peuple ukrainien a déclaré le
maire dans cette vidéo
l'onu s'inquiète d'une escalade des
opérations russes qui conduisent à leur
tour à une escalade des violations des
droits de l'homme
[Musique]
à kiev la chasse aux infiltrés aux
saboteurs aux collaborateurs restent
constantes on les attend surtout de nuit
mais on reste sur les nerfs à tout
instant
c'est en grande partie aux forces de
défense territoriale qui reçoivent
encore des volontaires tous les jours
qu'il revient de les intercepter
le moral est bon dix réservistes qui ne
comprend pas que le monde s'étonne que
les ukrainiens résistent encore à une
armée plus imposante
plus grands ne veut pas dire plus fort
10 capitaine nous sommes plus motivés
nous nous battons pour notre pays eux
quand ils rencontrent de la résistance
une perdre le moral ils ne veulent pas
mourir nous ça ne nous fait pas peur de
mourir
mourir s'il le faut dit il pour que plus
aucun enfant comme ce garçon de 13 ans
ne soient gravement blessé par les tirs
et les explosions qui pleuvent sur
l'ukraine
et pour rendre une certaine normalité
ici le plus importante hôpital
pédiatrique du pays
certains diront d'eux qu'ils sont des
victimes collatérales
il serait peut-être plus juste de parler
des oubliés de la brutalité des grands
depuis cinq jours chaque fois que les
sirènes d'alert retentissent au des sus
de kiev il se retrouve ici dans le
sous-sol de l'hôpital
kirill et ses petites copines souffre de
leucémie leurs corps fragilisées par la
maladie et les traitements de
chimiothérapie il devrait être en
isolement strictes ce n'est plus
possible
marina la maman de kirill est rongé
d'inquiétude il doit subir un traitement
demain une fois lancé impossible de
l'arrêter trois heures à prier pour que
les sirènes se taisent
nous avons déjà notre guerre avec le
cancer dit elle est là encore ça
[Musique]
totalement jeudi je souhaite que le
monde entier puisse contribuer à ce que
ça se termine le plus tôt possible
ce ne sera pas pour cette nuit marina
sitôt le jour tombe et kiev a de nouveau
été ébranlée par de puissantes
explosions
ici marie ève bédard radio-canada kiev